hello guys my name is Jenna and welcome
to episode 116 of game programming so
last time we changed our UI manager to
use Javas graphics class so that we
could end up with rather high-resolution
text and and rendering in comparison to
our game which is well we made our
engine to be rather low resolution to
match a certain aesthetic and we don't
really want to have that same limitation
with UI so what we've done is utilize
Java's graphics class to rent us and
pretty high resolution stuff compared to
our game now that being said today we're
actually going to use the UI for
something one thing I should mention
that we can do by the way is and I'm not
sure if you want to do this from a
performance point of view but you can
since we're rendering this on top of the
other image we can actually add
transparency to this and and not make it
fully solid so you can see the game
being neat like you can see the game
behind your user interface if you really
wanted to and I don't know how to do
that but I think well I imagine you
probably can do that it might be in the
color let's take a look at color class
our GPA has alpha so yeah it looks
pretty good okay so what we can do is
basically set this to true and this
should give us just nothing okay worked
you can see you can see the game behind
this right and of course we can make an
alpha of I don't know let's just say
half and you can see can see became
through it now you might want to do
something like that and by the way that
was totally possible without previous
setup it just would have meant that we
would have had to render a separate kind
of layer and a separate rendering target
otherwise of course it doesn't or we
could have I guess done actual blending
that that would be horrific Lee slow
without hardware acceleration so let's
not do that anyway the point is here we
have this and this is still running
pretty quickly you can do something like
this I'm not sure if I really want to
because
well Ramallah mad God doesn't do it and
it might be weird cuz you'd be clicking
on your interface but like maybe you
wouldn't want to see that I don't know
it just it looks a bit weird but the
point is you can do stuff like that if
you really want to where probably you're
just gonna stick with a solid because if
we do stick with solo that also means
that we don't have to render almost a
better thought about a quarter of our
screen we just do not need to render
okay which of course will in turn boost
performance as well because the game
will only be rendered in this like
viewport which is essentially even low
resolution and the rest okay cool
and by the way the way we could do that
is if you if you just really want to
kind of experiment with that on your own
is if we want to game and instead of
drawing this image to get height we
could draw it at say in fact what we
really should be doing is drawing this
at Witts timescale and this will become
apparent because I mean right now it's
not gonna it's actually gonna look
exactly the same or it should yeah no
change
but when we want to reduce the width by
a little bit so that was like 80 times
three I think you can see we can't
actually do that now all right now it
just squishes everything because we
aren't really conditioned for that but
if we do this then you can see it works
and I don't actually oh whoops
yeah it's my bad that sets the width of
the screen as well so we'll set the
width to that we'll keep the width there
but now this is where this comes into
handy yeah this really isn't lying isn't
it okay for now let's just add on eighty
times three to that it's still not
rendering a bit lovely why is it not
doing that oh yeah
there we go so you can see now it's
actually physically not rendering
anything by an Hollow and you can see
the frame rate almost went up by like
about 800 1000 frames per second even as
opposed to what it was before okay so we
can do that now it's no longer rendering
anything there so if I were to go ahead
and like if we were actually clearing
the screen we're actually not like is in
we're not drawing anything behind the
pixels erase if I get rid of it nothing
will happen but if I was first drawing
say a pink rectangle which actually was
the size of the screen all the sides of
our window which is right over here
and I've set the color to I don't know
pink okay um and I got rid of you I
managed it at random you can see that
there we go it's pink so nothing is
actually being rounded there so I'm
actually gonna keep it like this for now
because well because we don't think we
want to render anything behind that and
you can see it does obviously since we
were waiting hard-coded our positions
and one on players position as well the
levels based on the players position do
you see the players now in the middle
before he was like here because he wore
the rendering the Atty thing so this
might be a bit nicer as well of course
if we still click on the UI panel we
still get full input and whatnot because
it doesn't know it's we're just with the
whole it's taking input from the entire
window basically from the entire canvas
which is the entire window but basically
we've got everything working pretty well
and you can see nothing's be around it
there I'm gonna keep this here just for
testing purposes and just to make sure
that we haven't missed anything because
you can see if we just read nothing it's
just gonna be all pink so we can see
easily if we've got any kind of holes in
our rendering because we shouldn't cool
anyway there you go all good in the hood
so ah
that being said now we kind of reread
done our game and you can see how easy
that was as well that's totally fine so
let's go ahead and look at some realm
thanks
and actually before we do what I want to
do is I'll show you guys this so these
are the China token forms so it's just
the chant of calm slash forums one thing
I want to mention is that I get
questions about where can you get help
regarding general programming or game
programming the the series or whatever
okay and this is definitely the place
you can see how many posts there are
here in the game for anything these
definitely get answered I'm usually on
these forums as well and I've been doing
a lot of answering lately but the idea
is if you guys want to talk about
anything regarding game programming in
general not just the game programming
series so whether it begin programming
or just programming in general you
certainly can so go to these forms
register and this is this is the place
to get help and to talk about game
programming so there you go anyway let's
look at some more realm of the mad God
stuff images well it's it let's take a
look at their setup because we are
effectively trying to clone their game
not because like we're trying to make a
run with a mad girl clone it's just that
we've chosen again that we want to try
and recreate for the purposes of
learning how to make games and this
seems like a pretty good can't it cool
so there we go that's actually tiny
resolution let's try and get some high
resolution stuff maybe I don't know if
there are high resolution stuff that
we're gonna be very high res yeah and
most that doesn't include panel okay
this one does cool this is like Full HD
here but um you can see well okay so
they've got a bit of a the player the
players name a button to return to the
Nexus or whatever is called to the
central thing I haven't played this game
in like three years by the way since I
started the series but um oh this has
changed this isn't it
Oh have it maybe I don't know anyway you
got your weapons down here I presume
these are just consumables and potions
and stuff you can actually just click on
to drink these are your main kind of
currently equip things yeah this is like
your trading thing actually I think it's
because he's standing over a player who
I don't know anyway I don't remember but
um the primary weapon died in our ammo
if its primary I don't know what that is
kinda look like arrows but who knows cuz
he a low-res this stuff is as well armor
and ring so what they've got is we're
gonna try and kind of start off with
here we're not we're gonna leave the
mini-map for last because that actually
isn't that's going to be an actual
rendering viewport as well because we
that's the way we're going to
however this stuff we need to design
using our UI so we've got the player's
name we really have a name for a player
so we should probably it on that we've
also got an icon based on which class
the player is and then a button over
there and then these three bars let's
kind of try and do that so today we're
going to probably integrate health as
well as a player name so we don't have
any health either so it's it's kind of
begin with that well actually we'll
start with a player's name so players
should have a name ok player since mob I
don't think mobs in general should have
names because well I don't know maybe
like enemies or significant non player
characters will but mobs in general know
so players should have names how do we
do that well we'll start off with we're
gonna put this here as sprites
okay water let's just do it up here
private string name okay so when you
create a player we're just going to say
you should given name this is actually
since this does take a keyboard this is
implying that it's say a local player
not a not a multi player kind of player
so this is actually us the person who's
playing this on their computer locally
and once we get to multiplayer that'll
be a whole different kind of ball game
but anyway right now we'll stick to this
so this name whoops equals name it's
quite cold in here I can't like like I'm
never good at typing when it's cold so
we'll make a getter and setter I find
I've done both apparently we won't make
a guitar we won't make a setup okay so
there we go got the got the name so I
imagine this cool arrow me somewhere oh
this isn't even there I want is it let's
do it for both constructors
I got no era so I knew that that wasn't
right alright now as you get an arrow
here it is and let's make sure we call
the player shadow
all right cool so what we want to do now
is this UI panel is going to be largely
cantock controlled by the player class
ok because why you might ask because it
or everything that UI panel displays is
basically relevant to the player right
it has nothing to do with something the
player doesn't see or something a player
doesn't know if you take a look at the
actual logical structure of our game you
would probably realize that hey
everything that is in that UI panel the
player class should have access to
because if the player class doesn't have
access to something it probably means
that it shouldn't be displayed to the
actual real physical world player or
human that is playing the game right so
a lot of game designers on programming
and all these patterns and whatever are
really really really logical ok so they
should make sense that being said we've
got this UI manager with a bunch of
panels so let's let's make a bunch of UI
stuff so private UI label and this might
open this probably won't change I won't
bother making it like this but we'll see
in a minute anyway so UI panel oh you
guys gonna love what I'm about to do now
I better just overhaul this whole thing
but um we've if we wanted to draw
something like that we could just go
panel to add component let's see a name
set color oh did I really close has it
been winked let's try and find it um
here we go so it's kind of greyish and
the backgrounds dark grey I'm matching
this for the sake of matching it by the
way if you guys want to change colors or
whatever you can do that so we'll set
the color of the player to be kind of a
bright grayish color so I might go like
bbbbbb and we want to drag this out with
a quite low
we'll position it later we can do that
live and let's see this had the color of
the panel low which we can just say
don't set color as a panel isn't it okay
that was a bit different than components
components probably should be components
actually so what does the super
constructor want a position done okay
because I've made it I made a component
pretty easily but the reason I did that
was just so that we can set the color
now I bet panel probably has its and by
that I mean so it's pretty dark so let's
set it to like all right dark it
actually is but maybe like 4f ish I
don't know just set it to five zero but
anyway that looks pretty good probably
and that returns UI component so well we
can just tossed it we really wanted to
since we actually want this to
explicitly be a UI panel it doesn't need
to be it could be a UI can but I don't
think we're doing anything panel related
here I guess we having if yeah doesn't
matter anyway
all right I'm actually will because that
panel takes in a panel anyway um the
other thing that it probably does have
is call let's get rid of that it's
dangerous
same with position and we definitely
want to have G because of that okay cool
so if we run this now okay so kind of
darker that actually matches it pretty
well
as far as that goes looks like the text
is quite bold as well so what we can do
is don't set color dot set font oh
that's what's that's not right thing
over here
ah said font is bringing me down
it's totally that yeah the problem with
this is that set color returns the UI
component so let's do this instead
because I could fix this by the way
yeah let's fix it this is the worst fix
ever just because it looks messy so set
font new font Helvetica little will make
it bold so font up bold I hope that's
the right font it is and the size like
maybe you like yeah I think 32 was a
good size really we just wanted to make
it bold so if we run this now it's bald
is it a bit too big no it's fine okay
and then let's kind of position this a
bit so if we go into your white label
I'm just going to add like 50 pixels so
I'm it needs to be under the minimap
doesn't it so probably around there's
good right the mini-map is going to be
that big we should make it a bit smaller
as well but the Esso plus 100 that's all
you want so let's go back to player and
add that name at 200 and yeah let's make
it about 24 all right there we go
sounds pretty good that's our name we
should have our class next to it as well
so let's move it over a bit bit more
probably not mush
okay looking pretty good we'll have our
class icon here and then we'll have like
the nexus button or whatever to return
on it or if we'll have that based on our
game but we mind cool there we go done
um if we really want it by the way if
you really you can see that this one has
like a bit of a shadow around it it's
it's really just got it like a black
outline what we really could do really
wanted to was actually give it an
outline and the quick and dirty way to
do that is just to basically set the
color to black
and then just do how we just set the
font to new font font I get name bumped
up get style and font up get size plus
like - I guess we'll do this actually
since we've invested so much time into
it that'll just draw a black and plus -
was it the mistake I'll make it plus one
so it's a little bit bigger and then we
just offset it a little bit so - one -
one maybe and might take a bit of skill
to position this properly but that
actually seems to just be increasing it
horizontally for some reason that's
quite weird okay let's do this instead
actually quite surprised that it's not
it's barely affecting the goat at all it
is more like a drop shadow it's a very
bad one
let's just set this to zero did I even
do anything
was it not that's very weird
Blaine yeah actually doesn't seem to be
doing anything wet enough let's do this
why exactly is that doing nothing what
font is this telev Attica riot yeah okay
this is interesting that lacks a plane
and vulvar piling the same that's what
we did yeah well okay I didn't realize
that this had no bolt but apparently
doesn't anyway that yeah that that just
gets annoying okay so you can add a bit
of a shadow or a drop shadow by doing
this yeah that just does that just looks
tragic so we're gonna get rid of that
anyway um you guys get the idea you
probably should do it with a nicer font
maybe a monospaced font as well okay
cool
in fact a dealer maybe we should use a
more spaced font like what's something
that's Korean you isn't pump and
Gonzalez is but that just looks like a
typewriter what about just Korea
anyway this game I mean this this this
part of the of making the game is going
to be all about just trial and error and
just practicing I'm practicing but oh
okay yeah the data clearly supports bold
that is bold that's not so to bold yeah
so I don't know you flare out that
actually quite like Madonna might stick
with that so there's our name I wonder
if we made that bold whether I would
look alright who knows
let's set the font to your font so if we
set it to bold OH
bold bold just makes it scarily bold and
then no anyway
failing that what you could do is you
could simply render it again at an
offset of like that what has that done
what well it's the phone being set
somewhere else you could just do that
you can see that always pretty well if
you really wanted a bit of a shadow okay
so well we might actually just keep it
that way so this is if you want a shadow
so what I might do is make a public
bullying drop shadow
and if drop-shadow we do that done so
new feature so we can probably get rid
of this horrific nurse now because I'm
going to just say your why label name
label is that name label that set Color
Oops name level that's that font name
label duck drop shadow equals true name
label alright there we go
so now at least we've got the drop
shadow stuff for everything and it will
look pretty good so if we scale it up or
make it bold or whatever so probably
just make it bold like that
you can see that the shadow carries
along pretty well and if we make it much
much larger you can see that that shadow
day actually adds quite a bit to it it
looks quite nice you might if you were
doing it at 240 you probably want to do
something like I don't know more offset
to make it look a bit like this but you
can see it looks quite nice okay in fact
I might want to do something like +3
even though we're kind of at 24 maybe
not maybe that'll be a bit too extreme
who knows yeah that's a bit extreme so
we'll make a public int over 10 public
int drop shadow offset
- is the default and you can adjust it
if you like alright so there's a player
name now being displayed in the UI panel
looks pretty good so that's gonna be it
for this episode since this did take
quite a while but next episode we're
going to add the health bar and it
should be awesome if you guys enjoy this
episode please don't forget to hit the
like button and I will see you guys next
time goodbye
you